hello 18 I've enjoyed the chaos we're  getting ready for the premiere that's  Kristy being the real-life mom that  Jennifer Garner plays in her new movie  miracles from heaven we were with the  whole beam family as they were getting  ready for the big event including  thirteen-year-old Annabelle who the film  is all about excited for it and I want  to take a lot of pictures so I can  remember it  Annabelle kept a video diary of her  adventures for us the best part though  all this you're all dolled up you're on  the red carpet I mean what has been your  favorite part so cool what an amazing  night through the beam family I'm  telling you right now they walk that red  carpet like pros